uwe ritzer ist uns nun zugeschaltet und
süßer biograf kennt ihn also kann ihn
einschätzen
herr ritter wie sehen sie das ist markus
söder jemand der sollte sich heute den
kommenden tagen herausstellen dass armin
laschet der unions kanzlerkandidat wird
der dann in die zweite reihe zurück
tritt und lastet auch wirklich mit
ganzem herzen unterstützt und mit seinem
ganzen team mit der vollen power also
mit zweite reihe ist bei markus söder
überhaupt nix markus söder war nie ein
mann für die zweite reihe und er wird es
auch diesmal nicht sein
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass er aus
gründen der unions ressort armin laschet
unterstützt
du willst auch nicht als quer 3 war am
ende vermutlich schuld sein wenn die
wahl in die hose geht
aber markus söder ist glaube ich eher
der entspanntere von beiden im moment
erwartet einfach ab was die cdu
entscheidet jetzt setzt er in der ganzen
zeit vor allem auf die basis möchte in
immer wieder anderen formen dass die
menschen abstimmen können ihre meinung
mitteilen könne man sieht auch dass die
basis in großen teilen hinter ihm steht
ist das in seiner karriere schon immer
so gewesen
nutzer können sie mich noch hören
also da versucht ihr jetzt in den
letzten tagen immer wieder die
entscheidung von ganz oben weiter nach
unten zu geben die basis sollen
mitbestimmen
das wollen auch viele seiner befürworter
er hat viele unterstützer in der basis
ist es in seiner karriere schon immer so
gewesen oder das ist ein novum für
markus söder genau von dort jetzt
unterstützung zu bekommen
er war schon immer ein politischer
guerillakämpfer und zwar von seinen
nürnberger anfängen der jungen union an
auch seine erste landtagskandidatur 1994
hat er sich so erobert markus söder war
nie der kandidat des partei
establishments es gab in seiner karriere
nur eine einzige situation wo er von der
parteiführung befördert wurde das war
als edmund stoiber ihn damals zum
csu-generalsekretär gemacht hat
ansonsten
hat markus söder immer die mehrheiten
für sich organisiert die basis für sich
organisiert und dann ist die schlacht
gezogen und das hat er in dieser woche
im mustergültig wieder genauso gemacht
er hat erst mal abgewartet dann trat
dann trat plötzlich armin laschet vor
die vor die medien und sagte der
präsidial ich habe doch alle meine leute
hinter mir und dann kam markus söder und
dann begann die große bunte bilder show
und dieses oder party ist glaube ich
noch nicht vorbei sie sagen dieser
partie ist noch nicht vorbei dennoch
rein wir uns hier zumindest in berlin
bisschen verwundert die augen was da in
den vergangenen stunden passiert ist
denn man hatte so ein bisschen das
gefühl dass markus söder eigentlich seit
gestern spätestens im aufwind ist dass
es immer mehr stimmen gab die sich für
ihn ausgesprochen haben das ist
basisbewegungen gab jetzt kann natürlich
da im bundesvorstand alles passieren
aber selbst mit denjenigen mit denen man
spricht die für söder waren waren
zuletzt überrascht und haben gesagt sie
verstehen nicht warum er gesagt hat dass
er hinter einem möglichen votum im
bundesvorstand steht und sozusagen den
ball in richtung armin laschet gespielt
hat also warum hat er das gemacht gab es
dann doch die sorge dass weil die cdu
granden wolfgang schäuble volker
bouffier weil alle diejenigen gestanden
haben dass das am ende eng für ihn
werden könnte warum hat er zum beispiel
nicht gesagt na ja wir brauchen ein
breites votum kreisverbands konferenz
abstimmung in der fraktion warum gibt
der armin laschet jetzt diese
möglichkeit einen elfmeter zu verwandeln
heute abend na ja die frage ist doch ob
dieser überhaupt einen elfmeter ist also
ich meine warum soll er eine
kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz oder sowas
verlangen warum soll eine abstimmung in
der fraktion verlangen
die hat er doch im grunde hinter sich
und er weiß auch ganz genau dass sowohl
armin laschet als auch die restliche
cdu-führung genau wissen dass die basis
mehrheitlich markus söder will dass die
umfragen sowie so haushoch für markus
söder sprechen das weiße doch alles nein
ich glaube das war heute großes
staatsschauspiel
das war so die möglichkeit wenn es sich
auch er hat sich zwei türen aufgemacht
die eine tür ist wenn die cdu mich ruft
ja dann dann komme ich natürlich aber
selbstverständlich liebe cdu respektiere
ich dass du die größere die wichtigere
partie ist also auf bundesebene also
werde ich ein votum akzeptieren wenn das
votum für markus söder ausfällt kann er
immer sagen ihr habt mich ja gerufen
wenn aber das votum jetzt für armin
laschet ausfällt dann hat es sich auch
eine tür aufgemacht und kann sagen
schaut mal ich habe ja nur gewollt dass
wir alle diskutieren und er kommt ohne
gesichtsverlust aus dieser nummer wieder
raus denn über eines müssen wir uns
schon im klaren sein warum zahlen markus
söder hat in diesem spiel im moment so
gut wie überhaupt nichts mehr zu
verlieren denn wenn armin laschet
kanzlerkandidat wird bleibt söder csu
vorsitzender und ministerpräsident in
bayern und er hat etwas gemacht was der
csu das ist in bayern unheimlich gefällt
im moment er hat dieses bayerische mia
san mir
hinter dem sich die csu mindestens
genauso gerne versammelt wie der fc
bayern
das hat er herausgekehrt er hat stärke
gezeigt und in der csu klopfen ihm viele
auf die schulter und sagen bravo markus
du hast denen auch gezeigt dass wir eben
nicht eine regionalpartei sind sondern
nach wie vor bundespolitisch wichtig
also schröder hat viel weniger zu
verlieren als laschet jetzt in diesem
moment erinnert ak die ehemalige
vorsitzende in der vorstandssitzung an
den beinahe bruch mit der csu 2018 akad
gerade im vorstand gesagt so hören wir
damals haben wir gesagt das darf nie
wieder passieren und ich zitiere weiter
was a kk dort gerade gesagt hat mit der
wahl zum parteivorsitzenden verbindet
sich auch der anspruch kanzlerkandidat
zu werden ich erinnere an das gute
ergebnis von laschet beim parteitag das
ist schon erstaunlich ak galt eigentlich
nie als große unterstützerin von armin
laschet ganz im gegenteil sie fühlte
sich fast so ein wenig gemeuchelt von
ihm damals als sie noch
parteivorsitzende war das ist schon ein
klares zeichen oder wie sehen sie das
jetzt
aus der sicht von markus söder
möglicherweise also punkt eins an einen
drohen loch der verbindung der familie
cdu/csu glaube ich überhaupt nicht
markus reder hat bitter und leidvoll
erfahren wie das bei den
flüchtlingsstreit zwischen seehofer und
merkel zuging so was will er kein
zweites mal haben und was die geschichte
angeht was frau kramp karrenbauer gesagt
hat na ja aber das ist doch eigentlich
nur etwas ganz logisches aussprechen
die cdu hat einen monatelangen quälen
denn nachfolge kant was den cdu-vorsitz
angehen nach frau kramp karrenbauer
hinter sich gebracht dann wurde endlich
armin laschet gewählt du kannst dich
doch nicht zum grün zum vorsitzenden der
größten deutschen partei wählen lassen
und dann zwei monate später sorgen auch
neue aber kanzlerkandidatin anhalten
jahr will ich nicht werden
also ich glaube dass es einfach eine
selbstverständlichkeit dass wenn du
cdu-vorsitzender wirst anfang des jahres
und im september sind bundestagswahlen
dass du dann auch als kandidat zur
verfügung stehen muss person erika eine
frage noch in richtung markus söder und
zwar die meisten von ihnen kennt und
kennen ihn jetzt vor allem durch die
kubakrise er sitzt immer wieder an der
seite von angela merkel bei den crooner
gipfeln
was muss man über markus söder ansonsten
müssen wir mal nicht aus bayern kommt
sich da also noch nichts damit
beschäftigt hat er hat ja jetzt auch
immer mehr unterstützer egal wie weit
man da an den norden geht was es
vielleicht eine anekdote eine geschichte
von der sie uns erzählen können also
eine methode ich das mal so beantworten
markus söder war einer der von jugend an
24/7 politik gemacht hat und er ist
einer der politik auch mit der
entsprechenden konsequenz macht wenn
markus söder durch die tür kommt dann
ist das zwei meter politisches
testosteron und in der vergangenheit war
auch sehr ungeduldig das ist ja
wahrscheinlich immer noch wer kann sich
im lauf des lebens wird man ja älter
besser im zaum halten der flug dann
früher schon mal ein stift oder eine art
was söder aber besonders auszeichnet und
ich glaube das war auch der punkt warum
man diese beliebtheitsskala wert diese
beliebtheitswerte erreicht auf der skala
in der korona krise er kommuniziert klar
er redet teilweise auch ein bisschen
anders als das politiker gerne in ihren
floskeln tun er kann sehr gut
kommunizieren und er ist natürlich einer
der in einer union die von frau merkel
natürlich schon ein stück weit
sozialdemokratisiert wurde er verkörpert
er den aufrechten stehenden
konservativen denjenigen den so schnell
nichts umwirft den auch gegenwind jetzt
nicht so schnell aus der bahn bringt
aber wissen sie mit seiner
kommunikations kunst hat das ja auch
verstanden dinge die in der korona
bekämpfung in bayern schief liefen
eigentlich so unter der decke zu halten
oder zumindest klein zu halten da gab es
nie
große diskussionen in dem ausmaß die ihn
und seiner beliebtheit gefährdet hätten
wie das armin laschet in nrw erlebt hat
jetzt gab es noch eine aussage gerade
eben von a kk dort in der sitzung und
zwar hat sie gesagt sie berichtet von
vielen e-mails die das verhalten von
markus söder in der vergangenen woche
missbilligen können sich das vorstellen
dass es da viele gibt die aussagen
mensch was der markus söder gemacht hat
das geht eigentlich gar nicht ja das
kann ich mir schon vorstellen ich bin
jetzt kein intimer kenner der cdu aber
wenn sie sich mal noch mal vor augen
führen
er hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt
wir finden da eine gemeinsame lösung und
am montag gibt es dieses votum der cdu
spitze für wenn auch nicht mit einer
abstimmung unter legt dieses votum für
armin laschet laschet stellt sich hin
hält eine fast schon staatstragenden
rede ist auch von dem moment sicherlich
gerührt und dann kommt dass söder und
sagt auch wisst ihr was wir können doch
die basis das muss schon ein bisschen
breiter werden und dann redet er das ist
ja auch eigentlich fast schon frech
er redet davon dass die entscheidung
nicht in hinterzimmern fallen darf das
war ja eine ohrfeige fürs für die
cdu-spitze für präsidium und vorstand
und was sagt er heute ja ich respektiere
selbstverständlich wenn präsidium und
vorstand eine andere entscheidung
treffen als mich also soler ist schon
einer der kann da schon sehr schnell die
positionen wechseln
das ist im übrigen auch etwas was ihm in
bayern sehr sehr lange und auch bei der
letzten landtagswahl sehr angekreidet
wurde was komischerweise ihm aber jetzt
in der kanzlerkandidaten diskussion eben
nur in teilen in einigen stimmen wie sie
sie jetzt zitiert haben um ihm um die
ohren fliegt mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren